A few important things that patients
need to do in order to prevent a
recurrence?
Um,
well the first thing is to really
manage,
you know,
your own follow up appointments.
I think there's a few of us that were
surprised that doctors don't send that
little card out in the mail to remind
you,
like a dentist used to do,
uh,
to remind you of those followup
appointments.
It's your responsibility to manage those
and you've got several doctors
appointments to follow up depending on
the type of a treatment.
For me,
I had to,
to follow up with my surgeon and
oncologist,
my radiologist and a for a while first
year and my plastic surgeon.
Uh,
so there were several appointments that
I needed to,
to manage and monitor.
And that is critical that you stay on
top of that.
They're not going to call and remind you
it's,
uh,
doesn't happen and a,
so it's your responsibility.
I also believe that changing your
lifestyle is important.
This isn't the lifestyle you have had
cancer.
It's over.
You're done.
We're hair starts to grow back and you
start to feel better and healthy and
your life moves on.
But at the end of the day you had cancer
and it's now lifestyle that you need to
monitor and manage.
That means,
uh,
you know,
looking at your diet and eating healthy
foods.
Um,
there's been a big link to um,
uh,
having,
having extra weight and,
and fat in the Diet and on your body,
a linking with cancer.
So being healthy and eating well,
exercise.
Um,
and just being very cognizant of how
you're,
you feel on a day to day basis,
how your body feels and recognizing any
potential symptoms to,
you know,
make that phone call.
If there's any concern.
Well,
I'll tell you,
I definitely treated this cancer a
little differently than the first one.
I knew to take care of myself.
I need to stay positive.
I need to wait to find out all the
information.
Uh,
when I went to see my doctors before I
panicked,
before I went to the website.
So I implemented everything that I,
uh,
you know,
from experience.
I,
I did exactly what I tell everybody else
to do.
I followed the rules.
I called my insurance insurance carrier.
I,
uh,
made sure to have all my questions ready
before and prepare it before my doctor's
appointments.
I had all my paperwork and my slides,
pathology report.
I,
uh,
asked all the questions and had several
opinions before we went ahead and made
the final decision of the ta type of
treatment that I would,
uh,
take on.
So,
and even going through the process,
like,
I hate to say it,
but a variant cancer,
I thought,
you know,
I had breast cancer.
I know what the surgery is going to be
like.
I've had that.
I've,
you know,
I've had chemotherapy.
Well,
it was
okay
about 10 times harder,
uh,
with the surgery and the chemo.
That was a bit of a surprise.
But the process remains exactly how I
knew to get through it.
And I was able to stay positive and keep
my family from panicking and my friends
from panicking,
which is unfortunately one of the jobs
that are not,
uh,
sometimes we end up taking on is keeping
everybody else calm.
Um,
when your friends and families start to
really panic.
But I was very lucky.
I got again,
an opportunity to see some wonderful
doctors I had.
Um,
I what else?
I have my counselor one on one planner
and Aye.
Aye.
Yeah,
just before I was about to go to pressed
as to prepare this planner for people
with breast cancer,
I had to stop the process where we're at
in the middle of editing and about to
send it to the printer.
And I grabbed the prototype and I used
it and I though it was designed for
people with breast cancer.
I was the organizer component.
Um,
that really got me through the process
and was able to keep me calm and focused
about my next steps.
I had a place to put all my
appointments,
my notes,
my business cards,
and it really helped my mother who was
flew in from Chicago to be with me.
You know,
as a mother,
she was just devastated.
So I think the plan are really kept us
both organized and everything.
All our notes were in one place where we
could share this book together.